the three boys put on their wellies
they ran down the field
they swam on the swing
they rolled down the corn cyrcle
they came to the river
they sat on the edge
dangling their feet over the stream
Look! - said Rupe
the sandy beach
sure enough, they saw there
was little tiny beach of sand
Terence said
the land reaches down into the water
and Rupert said
no, the water reaches up into the land
Ralph said - it's both
water and sand
it's the sandy beach
it's a fractal object
they stood then, they walked in the stream
Look! - said Terence
it circles to the left
No - said Rupert
it circles to the right
it"s turbulent flow
said Ralph - it's a mathematical object
it's chaos
on the other side
of the stream, there was no beach
there was a concrete wall
it was not a fractal object
Rupert said
it's a straight line
Terence said
it's a Bauhaus excrescent of post-linguistic humanoids
thinking of peanut-butter sandwiches then, they walked back up the slope
Rupert said
nature has given us a lesson
nature is our teacher
we have learned about the sandy beach
the sun had set
Ralph pointed to the sky
Look! - he said. They looked and saw
there was a silver stripe in the sky shining there
they hadn't noticed it before
it girduld the entire celestial bolt
it sprang from two legs
to the south that way, they saw that
it's two legs appeared in the zodiacal belt
it sprang across the mid-heaven, going somewhere near the polar constellations
Rupert said
I think those constellations over there, those are all watery
there's Pisces, there's fish
it's biology projected on the sky
Terence said - the Calvea astrologers called that the celestial sea
and Ralph said
it's a sandy beach in the sky
and Rupe said
Father Sky is our teacher too
Ralph said - Well, there's
a sphere above the sky
with the sandy beach in it
and a kind of astral projection
imprints its shadow on the celestial sphere
and on the terrestrial disc as well
they went back to the kitchen and tugged off their wellies
and looked for peanut-butter in the fridge